on le sait le coronavirus prend de plus
en plus de place en europe et aux états
unis si toutes les mesures sont prises
pour protéger les citoyens il en est de
même pour les stars et les responsables
politiques particulièrement exposés en
raison du nombre important de personnes
avec lesquelles elles soient en contact
alors que céline dion devait annuler un
concert en raison d'un rhume de dernière
minute les fans de la star s'inquiétait
de savoir si cette maladie était liée ou
non avec le coronavirus très vite tester
les nouvelles ont été rassurants après
lui avoir fait passer un test les
médecins ont conclu que son virus
n'était pas lié aux coronavirus du côté
des états unis donald trump continue de
minimiser l'importance du coronavirus si
les usa ont mis un temps très long pour
réagir face à l'épidémie
8 milliards de dollars viennent d'être
débloqués pour commencer à tester des
citoyens une période de test qui a pris
du retard et qui pourrait faire exploser
le nombre de contaminés dans les jours à
venir le président américain a pourtant
été en contact avec au moins deux
personnes atteintes par le virus
l'un d'entre eux a voyagé lundi à bord
même de l'avion que lui l'autre l'avait
accompagné lors d'une visite officielle
pourtant selon les proche de donald
trump il n'a pas besoin d'être testé
même si le président précise lui-même
qu'il est prêt à l'être en france aussi
le virus fait peur aux stars malade
depuis ce week end et mbappé aurait lui
aussi été testées pour le coronavirus un
test visiblement négatif puisqu'il ne
s'agirait que d'une angine et pour
certains ce coronavirus représente un
peu plus qu'un simple test à passer
la chanteuse katy perry qui
s'apprêtaient à célébrer son mariage
avec l'acteur orlando bloom depuis juin
au japon aurait décidé de reporter leur
mariage à une date ultérieure en raison
de l'épidémie
bref un virus qui n'a pas fini de faire
parler de lui
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya des concerts
des festivals
voilà qui sont annulés c'est vrai que
c'est un pauvre week est bon pour keen'v
par exemple qui a vu sa tournée fera en
france annulé il avait une soldate
maintenu à rouen
et là tout était il ya deux jours en
disant que c'était susceptibles d'être
annulées donc par exemple pour qu'ils
essaient vraiment c'est incroyable ça
c'est ça qui nous moi je vous dire je
suis plus inquiet même pas aussi à
l'aspect économique inactive a touché
énormément de l'homme et le problème qui
a c'est aussi ça va toucher les plus
petits un forcément et qui vont le plus
souffrir origines porte dans le monde du
spectacle c'est dramatique n'y a pas que
là mais c'est sa touche là on en parle
et surtout il ya des concerts qui sont
reportés des spectacles et des concerts
qui sont reportés par exemple en
septembre vite a par exemple été
contente parce que c'était pas annuler
s'étaient reportés
mais le problème c'est qu'il ya quand
même une incertitude jusqu'en septembre
bien sûr qu'il va y avoir un engorgement
parce qu'il y avait des dates prévues en
septembre il ya l'euro oscillait oui on
sait pas si c'est un beau leo il
commença lieu au japon certains
commencent à dire dans le comité ouhlala
bien sûr c'est alors je vous dirais même
roland garros paris début avril y jouer
voilà et c'est zéro plus qu'un film ne
joue pas donc ça me fera deux semaines
de deux voilà de vacances il ya des
décisions aussi tu as été prise il ya un
gros coup qui a été un gros coup dur
pour m pokora
il était dimanche au concert à amiens il
s'est adressé à son public les larmes
aux yeux
il a expliqué toute sa déception de ne
pas pouvoir continuer sa tournée
regarder
[Musique]
comme ça c'est des choses qu'on peut pas
anticiper et mat on voit très très
tristes maths en plus c'est un carton sa
tournée et toutes les dates étaient
remplis à fond et c'est vrai que ça fait
beaucoup de peine oui oui par exemple
l'hôtel accorhotels arena à paris c'est
fermé jusqu'au 15 avril à la mêmes c'est
certainement jusqu'au mois de mai dire
que tout est annulé tous les spectacles
vous savez remettre toutes les scènes
ces fermes yves rondez coûte la lave on
vous dit les conséquences économiques
sont incroyables et pour les jeunes
carrières en province où les certains
événements sont très importants le
garçon vous connaissez le goût maniaque
et dans la région de chambéry où il
vivait que par des animations pour les
journalistes c'est déconcertant m
envoyant estimations jusqu'en juillet de
7 oui qui dit oui c'est hyper triste
pour les stars parce que c'est triste
mais on se remettre sur wii voilà avons
100 sur mon sens match je pense mais moi
je pense à toutes les personnes les
maquilleurs durée cumulée les chances et
des lumières des caméras ces choses là
pour eux c'est surtout un drame ce que
même en télé je vous dit énormément de
tournage il et j'ai eu des gens france
télévisions encore tout à l'heure qui
m'ont dit on annule toutes nos émissions
on a annulé interdite on a annulé vous
savez l'émission des régions ces animaux
cie voilà donc vous rendez compte il ya
plein de gens d'intermittents du
spectacle aussi qu'ils vont pas pouvoir
travailler les oublis et savez c'est ça
c'est vraiment pour moi c'est ça le plus
dramatique et on sait pas comment faire
alors on veut bien embaucher tout le
monde nous croquons à l'antenne mais on
va mettre deux cameramen a le derrière
des caméras tout ça on va voir mais bon
franchement c'est le même nous on ne
sait pas on fait l'émission au jour le
jour où lyon s'est pas voilà ce qui va
se passer si on va pouvoir continuer
sera pouvoir avoir toujours du public
mais c'est vrai que c'est compliqué où
les jambes parce que surtout ac et
essayèrent macro qui dit qu on n'est
qu'au début de l'épidémie mais la
pression déjà c'est rien a raconté après
la fin au début on est au début et on y
reviendra tout à l'heure je vous dirais
voilà ce que va certainement annoncé
emmanuel macron demain voilà je vous
lire dans un invité en plus si aucune
assurance qui fonctionne évidemment et
les tournages qui sont lancés c'est que
si un seul cas sur un tournage sur un
film par exemple il faut arrêter le
tournage et la gradation aucune
ingérence non pour les pandémie épidémie
aucune assurance
nos clients sont battus entre eux si un
seul cas ben c'est le temps d'arrêter
ses cinquante mille euros de pertes par
jour c'est considérable il faudrait
quand même alors vrai bras même ce soir
le psg mais ils n'ont rien et c'est un
manque à gagner énorme 5 millions on
parle de 5 millions d'euros sur la
recette billetterie
il y avait cette billetterie parce que
forcément il y aura personne dans le
stade ce soir mais rien pour un c'est un
des gros mc vous rendez compte 5
millions de paires pour le psg que
maintenant tout ça c'est énorme et c'est
pas fini parce que s'ils se qualifient
les matches tardent il ya déjà un
certain mathieu ça va être même pour les
mêmes dans le foot
et oui même le foot va être touchée à m6
on dit qu'il ya beaucoup d'argent dans
le foot forcément ils vont être touchés
et moi je vous dis j'ai d'autres infos
sur la tv donc je vous donnais dans un
instant qu'ils sont pas réjouissantes
pour le moment on parle du psg puisque
on a quand même voulu voir est ce qu'il
ya des supporters qui sont allés
encourager les joueurs du paris saint
germain
comme il ne reste qu'à des supporters
qui sont allés puisque c'est à huis clos
et on a le roi du duplex à challes base
des photos
sacha le basque et devant le parc des
princes à ramon sacha
bon
salut cheryl oui je suis devant le parc
des princes arrivé au bon moment parce
que c'est vraiment le bordel dumont
voyante elle est à chaque fois
alors petite question bonjour la sept à
huit clos pourquoi vous êtes venu à huis
clos alors que vous avez même pas voir
le match finalement bah voila moi je
viens de saint-omer près de lille
et juste pour m'imprégner de l'ambiance
ici du psg moi je viens le seul virus et
paris le virus et paris mais est-ce que
vous avez pas peur de la trappe et le
coronavirus tout pour paris je brade
tous les interdits moi je posais un
repos pour venir dans le pg et j'aime le
psg donc je viens ici et là est ce que
est ce que vous pose est ce que pensait
qu est ce que je pensais que les jouets
vous attendre
on a vu série les supporters sont très
chaud même si c'est à huis clos ils sont
là c'est magique à tous tes bons d'achat
et que je dois vous voyez l'ambiance aux
abords ne gagne pas c'est quand même du
monde et j'adorerais source a pas
franchement je brave voilà toutes les
maladies pour le psg